i feel kind of out of my element now the
real pressure
problem this feels weird oh that would
derail this entire thing
[Music]
welcome back to chef out of water i'm
alexis and i'm a chef who's always up
for a challenge i've taken to the
internet to see what appliance i should
use to make a three-course meal at the
end i'll have a surprise guest come on
and they'll try to guess what i used
[Music]
a blender
do i get anything else
why this is going to take some uh extra
creativity
okay here's my game plan i'm going to
make a three-course raw meal because
clearly i can't cook meat with this but
i think i can make something pretty good
and pretty exciting nonetheless
for dessert today i'm making a dark
chocolate mousse it's going to be a
learning experience for both of us first
i'm going to chop my
chocolate
problem the chocolate's not going to
melt in the blender
if i was doing this
you know with a stove i would use a
double boiler i might even use a
microwave
but i can't do that
[Music]
okay this is kind of crazy but
it's a really hot summer day in los
angeles i wonder if i'd
put the chocolate outside
in a bowl if it'll melt
[Music]
this is so weird
for the appetizer i'm going to make a
raw
walnut spread
pate i've never made
anything like this um so i'm not really
sure what to expect i'm not sure about
the consistency
the flavors heat brings out flavor which
i don't have the luxury of using
so i need to add flavor with other
ingredients first off i've been soaking
walnuts for
a little while soaking them is just
going to make them more creamy more easy
to blend i guess i'm going to start with
adding
some walnuts
some fresh herbs
got some sage rosemary
parsley
some olive oil
some nutritional yeast nutritional yeast
is just dehydrated yeast it adds this
really kind of like a nutty savory
flavor a lot of diets use it as a
replacement for cheese or like a cheesy
flavor sometimes it's called nooch too
little vinegar
i also thought some soy sauce could be
interesting just to add some complexity
[Music]
it smells kind of like a natural food
shop i feel like it needs more liquid it
needs something to make it more of more
spreadable
water
[Music]
i need some work
more water
you can see that it's starting to get
really creamy and pulverized at the
bottom the top isn't there yet but this
feels like the texture i want like
something smooth dippable
something like pate
typically pate is made out of liver and
it has a really smooth
buttery consistency
i don't think i can get it quite to that
degree but i'd like to get it more on a
dippable
[Music]
i kind of think this is as good as it's
gonna get i'm curious to see how it is
when it sets up after tasting this pate
i feel like i'm at a seven right now i
feel pretty confident
it's good
a little weird but it's good
oh my god this actually worked
it's not perfect you know some chunks
but
i think it's gonna work avocado for
creaminess i'm gonna add some coconut
cream from the top
also some coconut oil a little vanilla
pinch of salt
my sun melted chocolate look at that
it's pretty melty
i'm going to add half a banana just to
add a little more creaminess maybe a
splash of maple syrup
it's delicious i'm going to put the
mousse in these little ramekins to chill
for a few hours so they'll get set up in
more moose like and then i can move on
for my entree i'm going to make a raw
lasagna i'm going to use the zucchini as
noodles and make a pesto make a
sun-dried tomato
spread and a cashew ricotta i have never
done any of those things but i have had
lots of real lasagna so
you know
we'll see how it goes i'm going to
thinly slice the zucchini
and then let them sit out and sprinkle
them with salt to draw out some moisture
it'll also add some flavor to the
zucchini which
honestly they need because it's raw so
i'm going to put this off to the side
and move on to making my cashew ricotta
i've been soaking these cashews for a
while again that's just to make them
really creamy
wow the cashews feel really oh my god
they're so soft
i think it's gonna be pretty creamy so
for the nut pate i think i did about two
tablespoons and all so i think i can be
pretty generous with this especially if
i'm trying to emulate cheese i feel kind
of out of my element not because of the
blender but just because i'm making food
that i don't normally make and using
flavors and ingredients that i don't
normally use
[Music]
i don't eat a lot of nut-based cheeses
but this is what they look like you know
it doesn't totally look like ricotta but
i think once it's layered with the other
components it's going to kind of like
blend right in next up is my pesto
traditionally pesto is made in a mortar
and pestle but blender
totally fine i'm adding a bunch of basil
garlic this is a pretty big clove so
just gonna do half for now pine nuts
and then
some parmesan do not put parmesan
no dairy on this one
for our taste tester
great great
okay
it's really lucky for them that it is
all
raw and so far hasn't had dairy great
since we're going dairy free that means
no parmesan i'm going to use nooch as a
replacement for the parm it'll give that
umami nutty kind of savory flavor
[Music]
it's delicious i'm going to raise my
confidence level to an 8.
the last component of my lasagna is the
tomato sauce so i'm gonna have
some raw tomato some sun-dried tomato
garlic olive oil
oh it looks it looks really good
[Music]
i think the sauce is ready um i can
start assembling i think i'm gonna do
two
next to each other i'll start with a
layer of the tomato zucchini on top
[Music]
and then i think cheese
i think this looks really pretty
i actually think i would serve this at a
dinner
the layers on the side are so cool wow
wow this is really cool
i feel like
i feel like a proud mom
this is my this is my baby
wow
my dark chocolate mousse has set really
well you can
totally set i'm just gonna add some dark
chocolate shavings
maybe some salt some strawberries on the
side
simple elegant rustic last step for
plating is my walnut pate some olive oil
salt
some chives wow okay this looks great
i'm really excited to see if the taste
tester can guess what appliance i used
let's find out
hello my name is merle i was a tasty
producer for quite a few years and now
i'm a video producer for good full i was
a voracious meat eater for most of my
life and i've been vegetarian for four
years now and vegan for one year now fun
fact about me i can juggle so i'm about
to try the three courses that alexis
made for me and i really hope that i can
guess what the secret appliance was i
feel like i can
moment of
truth knock knock
this is a gift
what's up queen so good to see you
of everyone who could be eating this
meal you were the perfect person oh wow
cool wait i'm so excited course one
kind of looks like pate
but you wouldn't do that obviously okay
this is a dairy-free meat-free
okay so you are safe to eat it cool look
at all those little chives
[Music]
wow
punchy punchy
the acid really brightens with time holy
moly wow i feel like
very wealthy eating this
this is awesome
raw lasagna which is my pride and joy i
feel so excited it's so beautiful it's
also it's meat-free it's dairy-free
oh bless you
oh wow this is beautiful
okay here we go
[Music]
can i try it too
it's unbelievable the sauce dude
this is so good what is the sauce is
this sun-dried tomatoes yeah
and for dessert a dark chocolate mousse
which is also dairy-free
[Music]
it's like a pudding cup it just vanished
in my mouth it just evaporated
oh my god alexis truly
five-star yelp review get it post-mates
to me
so merle final question
what do you think i made these three
dishes with one appliance
i'm gonna say this because it's been
with me in the back of my mind all day
is it a blender it's a blender oh my god
it's a leather
you did it you did it wait no you did it
you did it i didn't do anything we did
it yay
that one better than i could have ever
imagined you know this morning i felt
kind of ambivalent
unenthusiastic and
you know this day totally turned around
i feel like i learned so much about what
you can do with a blender about raw food
i feel like i feel really inspired i
feel like my creativity is kind of
flowing
if you make anything really cool and
really unusual in a blender tag me on
instagram let me know
internet you thought you had me with the
blender but
it turned out to be a win
what do you think's in store next time
comment below
[Music]
you